good morning everyone it's great to see
you all in beautiful downtown Wireton
for Groundhog Day 2023. thank you
everybody
[Applause]
good morning Willie hey Court can I ask
you a couple of questions we got some
time right what is it 805 806
um it really must be under a tremendous
pressure this morning he is a little
nervous for his first school around but
uh he's ready he's up for the test he's
excited the fireworks are fantastic and
he kind of looked at me and give me the
eyes we're good yeah okay go so he's
ready thank you very much Willy's ready
are you ready
yeah who wants an early spring
who wants an early spring
you do or or longer extended winter who
wants that yeah really it's kind of like
50 50 here
um what time do we got exactly you know
806 ish okay let's get married she up
here the mayor is the only one as we all
know that can do this the right way so
so this is our first time being him so
we'll see what we can do okay so maybe
she's getting in there he's talking to
Willie he's conversing with Willie he's
doing his thing he's looking him in the
eye they're making eye are they making
eye contact they're making eye contact
so oh oh that that fast
that was quick now what mayor me she's
going to be doing he's going to be
conversing with the shadow camera
they're all getting together they're all
gathering around because Willie has gave
his prognostication he knows what's
going on Willie you are so adorable
look at those cute eyes okay
They're laughing they're all howling
back there okay so do do we have we
gotta go back one more time it's not
only 807 okay one more time okay going
back in
is it can we call this like a recount
what is this
over there
all right since it is 807 it is time to
get the prediction who's doing this you
excited
let's go make some noise
Willie didn't see his shadow and we are
gonna have an early spring
[Applause]
yes really